[Music]
the Oprah interview in 2013 that's why
you decided to come clean time it was
tough on that the reason that I decided
to sit with her was that not because we
did have an existing relationship and I
like Oprah I like Oprah I trust her but
I knew that I was going to get sued and
I knew I was going to get sued six ways
to Sunday when the report came out and
they stripped the titles I thought they
knew they were lining up right and so
you know what happens when you get sued
what's the first thing that happens you
get deposed
so did I want to sit with Oprah who I
liked and trusted or did I want to sit
in a small room at a lawyer's office
with a grainy video some guy just
hammered my ass and leaked in the video
so I said [ __ ] it I'm gonna I'm just
going to get it out there you glad you
did it it had to happen where she should
pathetic I think she was sympathetic I
think she felt a lot of pressure from
the journal you know sports writers and
journalists in the world to say you give
this [ __ ] some softballs you're done
and so he came out smoking right in and
a good friend of mine really sums it up
this way and I believe this he says for
non-cycling and sports fans it was way
too much right you're talking about
EPO and transfusions and all it was they
were like whoa and then for the cycling
fan it wasn't enough when I say enough
you didn't you didn't tattletale enough
you didn't rat it and you didn't say
enough so no one was satisfied
everybody's pissed you went into the
interview thinking at least now people
will feel sad I left there thinking wow
that was that was pretty good and it was
it was the way he was brutal brutal